All right. Hello, everybody.
Afternoon. Thanks for joining us. Thanks for finding the room.
I was just laughing that
I think two years ago when we had one of the first cachexia sessions at AACR,
we were really deep in the back, and everyone had trouble finding the room.
And so you can see how cachexia is exploding.
We now have a much easier room to find and more people in the audience, so it's
been excellent.
So this is an educational session to talk about the clinical and molecular
phenotyping of cancer cachexia. You may have noticed an earlier
session today which was mostly focused on the preclinical.
So we'll try to gear more towards the clinical, although my talk in the end
will try to straddle back and forth between clinical and preclinical.
Here are my disclosures.
So just to save some of our speakers time, I'll introduce cachexia broadly
in about one minute. So cancer cachexia is a disabling
wasting condition affecting over 80% of patients with advanced
cancer. That translates to somewhere between eight and 10 million patients
with cancer worldwide every year.
And it severely impairs quality of life, limits cancer
treatment and the duration of treatment, and contributes directly to
cancer death.
It's diagnosed clinically as 5% weight loss over six months, or
you can have 2% weight loss if your BMI is already low, less
than 20.
And in humans, we have a poor mechanistic understanding.
There's been numerous failed trials, and currently, there's no approved therapy in
the US or EU.
So just as a brief introduction on today's session,
we'll start with Ed Reznik from Memorial Sloan Kettering, who is really
redefining the field of cachexia and discovering novel features that you'll hear
about using patient data from the electronic medical record.
And then we'll move to Rich Dunn from University of Rochester Medical
Center, who will describe cachexia subtypes.
And then lastly, I'll discuss some translational data that we
have studying the mechanism of cachexia and immunotherapy resistance.
And with that, I will pass the baton to Ed.
All right, well, thank you very much, Marcus, for the invitation to speak.
My name is Ed. I'm a PI at MSK, and I lead
a computational lab that studies tumor metabolism and physiology.
And by way of that, we've sort of recently become interested in the last few years
about cachexia.
So how do I advance?
That arrow.
That arrow?
Hmm.
The directional arrow?
Yeah, the down arrow. Maybe.
Am I missing something?
No.
There maybe. Yeah.
Your
mouse is acting advanced.
Yeah, maybe they'll reset it.
Yeah.
The data that I'm going to show you is so cool that it actually crashed the system.
I apologize for that.
Now yours?
Yeah, sorry. It's fine. Yeah.
Try to click
here.
All right.
So these are my disclosures. I wish they had anything to do with cachexia, but they
don't. And this is an educational session, so I thought I would
try to impart on you some lessons that our group has learned in the
last few years about cachexia. I have to admit, I'm a student myself, so
I really can't say I know much.
But along the way of working on this problem, we've learned a few
valuable things that I think can sort of reorient
how people
study cancer cachexia in human cancer patients.
I didn't want to bury the lead, so I'm just going to tell you what they are.
The first one is that we view cachexia as an ongoing process.
What we've come to realize is that it's important to remember that many patients
just haven't experienced cachexia yet.
And the third lesson, which is probably the most valuable and impactful, is that if
you want to study this in humans, you actually have to look at
them. And as you'll see, that's a privileged thing
that physicians can do easily but computational biologists cannot do
easily. So Marcus mentioned that
while there are many overlapping criteria for cachexia, the sort of
common pattern among them is that you have to have a pre-specified amount
of weight loss, usually 5% of your body weight loss over a six or
12-month period.
And so what our group decided to do was to try to actually implement
that criterion. It's slightly non-trivial to do, but the idea is
that if you have a patient's longitudinal weight trajectory, you can
smooth it out and then look for windows of time when a patient
satisfies that criterion. They actually lose 5% of their body weight over six
months. This seems like a kind of minor math
exercise, but it actually proves to be very useful.
Because what it does is it sort of divides a patient's timeline
into these discrete time-restricted
windows. So
what we learned
is that essentially patients are--
If you discretize their time trajectories into these windows, then when you ask
questions about cachexia, you can sort of anchor them against the windows.
So for example, if you're interested in risk factors for cachexia, you would want
to take measurements before cachexia started.
If you're interested in the phenotype that cachexia imparts on you,
you would want to look within the window.
And if you want to understand the residual effect of cachexia, well, then you have
to look outside of the window.And importantly, for example,
you can anchor other kinds of interesting measurements against these windows.
So if you're interested in therapy, you can actually align therapeutic windows
against our cachexia windows.
So what we did is, using the rich data resource at MSK,
we aligned body weight trajectories in these windows against other kinds of
measurements in the EHR to try to phenotype cancer
patients with cachexia. So the kinds of data that we typically have are
serology, so usually CVCs and CMPs.
We have some data on therapeutic progression, and we have usually
some measure of baseline genomics.
Okay, so where does this get you? I think it gets you quite a lot.
So,
one of the puzzling things in the cachexia field is that some basic
information about prevalence and incidence is not widely available, and
it's not uniformly curated. And so what you can do is actually apply
this criterion and then just start counting arithmetically.
And what you find then is that for every disease, there's actually a nontrivial
burden of weight loss that meets the criterion for cachexia,
even in diseases that are not typically associated with cachexia.
So, for example, in melanoma, something like 30% of patients
experience at least one weight loss episode that meets the criteria for cachexia.
And even if you boost this to 15% weight loss over six months, that would be like
me losing 30 pounds over six months, every disease shows some
patients that experience this phenomenon.
And the important thing to remember, of course, is that this is not necessarily due
to the tumor.
The patients are experiencing therapy.
They're being treated for cancer, and so this is
the convoluted effect of all the things that are happening to a patient.
But what you can see is that diseases like pancreatic cancer, which we know are
commonly associated with cachexia, they come out at the top.
But then other diseases like kidney cancer, where you would just really never
associate with cachexia, they actually have a comparable prevalence
to other GI cancers like
colon adenocarcinoma.
So what you learn if you do this systematically across our data set is that, for
example, patients can experience more than one bout of cachexia.
I think that's not really acknowledged, but it should be intuitive.
There's no reason why they shouldn't be able to do that.
And some patients experience longer periods or bouts of
cachexia than others. Sometimes it's a very focal weight loss event,
sometimes it's not.
And interestingly, if you try and time the
cachexia against interesting landmarks in a patient's care, so for example, a
diagnosis or a death, what you see is that when patients are
approaching the end of their lives, they actually have a pretty uniform rate or
risk of cachexia. It's really a diagnosis that a lot of the variation
comes about. And so actually, that's really what drives the difference between RCC
and colorectal cancer. It's all diagnosis.
So what you can do also is you can anchor, again, interesting
phenotypic measurements against these time windows.
So here I'm showing you on the left a plot of albumin levels, which can be a marker
either of malnutrition or a problem with hepatic synthesis.
And you can see clearly that when you align them against a real patient's body
weight, it's clear that albumin goes down
during periods of weight loss. That should not be surprising, but because we have
60,000 instances of data just like this, we can use
mixed effects models to actually try and hone in on what the
physiologic signature of cachectic weight loss is.
And it has three broad features that I would say
surprisingly don't vary across diseases.
The patients are anemic. They seem to be experiencing malnutrition, at
least from the perspective of albumin, and they have liver dysfunction.
They have elevated liver function tests.
So that's the first lesson, that if you want to do this right, I think you have to
treat cachexia as an ongoing process and just anchor whatever measurements you
make against that. The second lesson, just to put it in a
more principled way, is that we view cachexia as a right-censored event,
something like overall survival or PFS.
And to illustrate why this is important, because we had so much genomics
data right from the get-go, we are trying to associate genomic
features with the incidence of cachexia.
And this is an example of a real plot that our
student, Venise made in 2023 that was very highly powered,
trying to associate genomic features with the risk of cachexia across diseases.
And I'm pointing out that on the y-axis is just the negative log 10 uncorrected P
values. So we have no statistically significant hits even
before a P value correction. There's nothing there in the
data. And part of the reason that there's nothing there is that you may have a
patient that's at very high risk for cachexia, but if they've just arrived at your
clinic, unless they overtly have cachexia already, they just
haven't had any adequate time to really develop cachexia.
They're still at very high risk, and it's just like disease progression or death.
And so what you can do is instead of modeling cachexia as a binary event, you can
model it as a time to event process.
And when you do that, you immediately start seeing signals.
So this is, for example, P53 mutation in one adenocarcinoma.
The signal should be really apparent to you. It's highly significant.
If you do this across diseases, what you find is that there are many genomic
correlates of risk of cachexia, and the clear smoking
gun is P53, which I don't think is really canonically
associated with cachexia in the literature.
If you don't believe me, we actually validated these findings at
Dana-Farber. We also validated them by correcting for various
demographic and clinical factors, including, most importantly, clinical stage.
And we also validated it by looking at dose responses.
So as you up the minimum weight loss that you need to be called
cachectic, the signal that survives is really P53.
So it's clear that P53 in several disease contexts is highly
associated with risk of cachexia.
So all the stuff I've told you so far
is actually in a preprint that's in revision right now.
And the third lesson is totally unpublished, but I think is really
exciting andThe lesson that I
think brought us to that work is that we realized that if we wanted to study
wasting in people, we actually had to look at them And I
mean it literally because I came to learn that there was
a major difference between the physicians and the scientists in our lab, the
PhDs who are studying cachexia, and that the physicians
repeatedly encountered patients and had an intuitive understanding
of how they were actually losing weight and wasting, and in contrast, the
PhD scientists really did not. And so we had to find a way
to actually look at the patients that we were
proposing to study. So we came up with this hypothesis,
admittedly post-hoc, that we could use routinely
ordered CT data to understand how patients' bodies change
during cachexia. And ideally, we could use that
information to define subtypes of cachexia.
And what would distinguish this from other approaches is that
this would be based totally on anatomy rather than molecular features.
So
what's our approach to this? This work is led by Sonia in the lab.
Basically, we look for weight loss episodes that meet the clinical criteria for
cachexia, and then we identify CT scans that flank
the weight loss period, so a CT scan before, a CT scan after.
And then we analyze those CT scans for changes in body composition and
anatomy.
So what does our data set look like? We started with 60,000 patients.
Through some attrition, we landed at about 5,000 patients for where we
have both pre-cachexia and post-cachexia CT scans
heavily dominated by colon and pancreas cancer.
But actually there are some weird diseases in there too, like melanoma.
And what we do is we use a
computational algorithm called OSNIR that automatically analyzes
CT scans
by segmenting those CT scans into interesting body compartments and
then calculating
quantified features of those body compartments.
So what OSNIR specifically does is it navigates to a
predefined spinal level in the axial series.
We use L3, but actually they're all pretty equivalent.
And it automatically segments skeletal muscle, visceral fat, subcutaneous
fat, and then it also segments organs, and it tells us interesting information
about those compartments. So it tells us areas, radiographic
densities, and in the
context of organs, it tells us volumes.
This is an example of a patient pre and post cachexia, and you can see
they're pretty different. This patient loses a ton of fat and
almost no muscle.
So if we do this across our entire trial cohort, we see a few interesting things.
One is that,
not quite unanimously, but pretty uniformly, patients
lose fat and muscle, intramuscular fat,
visceral fat, subcutaneous fat, and skeletal muscle, but organ changes in
volume are more heterogeneous. Sometimes you see organs go up in volume, sometimes
you see them go down.
And so if you give a computational biologist a matrix of data, it's
unsurprising that they would try to cluster it.
So that's what we did. And what we arrived at,
surprisingly, is three pretty clean clusters of data.
And so remember, every one of the columns in this matrix
is a patient,
and all of them are losing weight. They all meet the clinical criteria by weight
loss for cachexia, which is the criterion that, for example, is used in the
penciclib trial. So everybody's losing weight, but they have
these variations in how their anatomy changes.
So what defines these clusters? So type A and type B in our hands
are characterized by profound adipose loss.
They all lose a ton of fat and muscle.
But actually what differentiates them is what happens in the
organs. So in type A, you see progressive increases in spleen
and liver volume. And in type B, you see atrophy of the organs
that's correlated to an increase in radiographic density across all
the organs. It's not restricted to one organ.
So it's as if in type A, the organs are getting bigger.
In type B, they're getting smaller and becoming more radiodense.
This is a prototypical example of a type A cachexia patient.
You can see that their subcutaneous fat goes down a bunch.
I don't know if you can see my mouse, but if you actually look at this orange
region over here, this is the spleen.
And if you orient yourself against the rib, it's clear that the spleen is getting
much bigger post cachexia, despite the fact that they're losing a ton of
weight.
So if you try and pin these against overall outcomes, for example, correlating
against survival at the end of the cachectic episode, what you find
is that the type A subtype with progressive increases in spleen and liver volume
does the worst almost uniformly across diseases, although not
completely uniformly.
And so we have this sort of framework now for
categorizing the subtypes.
But we don't really know
what is going on, what might be the etiology of them.
So the way that we approach this is to actually, again, repurpose our blood lab
data. Here I'm showing you a plot of the neutrophil to lymphocyte ratio, which is
sort of a marker of systemic inflammation.
And I'm stratifying patients by subtype and
sort of tracking their NLR across the weight loss episode.
So what you find is that actually the type A patients, actually all the patients
start at a relatively similar NLR.
But by the end of the episode, the type A patients have
massively elevated NLR as if they're systemically inflamed.
At the same time, actually, the type A patients start with the highest albumin, but
by the end of cachexia, they have the lowest albumin, and they're the only ones
that have albumin that actually falls below the critical threshold for calling
hypoalbuminemia.Finally, if you look in liver function
tests, it's clear that there's something messed up about the type A
cachexia patients in their liver.
Okay, so from this, we basically arrived at a simple hypothesis, which
is that we think that the type A patients exhibit markers
of systemic inflammation that may not be so evident in the other
subtypes of cachectic patients. How would we
test that?
One non-trivial implication of that is that if you could somehow measure organs,
phenotype organs in the body, not just using radiographic information, but using
molecular measurements, you would see evidence of inflammation in the organs.
So we were very lucky because there was actually a group doing this at our
institution. This is a collaborative effort between David Lydon,
Bill Jarnagin, who's the surgeon, and Robert Schwartz, who's the
hepatologist, where for about 40 patients who were
receiving pancreatectomies, during the surgical
procedure, a piece of the uninvolved non-metastatic liver
was profiled. They took a chunk and they submitted it for RNA-Seq.
And if you actually get the CT scans for these patients, what you see is that
they're roughly evenly divided between type A, type B, and type C
cachexia. And when you compare the gene expression programs in
the uninvolved liver prior to weight loss
between type A and type C, what you see is that type A livers seem
to already exhibit the signature of
elevated downstream inflammatory signaling.
So what you would really like to know is if the signal is coming from
the tumor or from somewhere else, what the extent of systemic involvement
is.
So we tried to do this, and it's a difficult
ask. And the reason is that if you want to profile
risk factors for cachexia, you need tissue, again, that is
collected prior to the onset of weight loss.
So somehow you need the surgery to happen or the biopsy to happen
before weight loss, and now you're doing this in a retrospective cohort with all
kinds of other attrition. It's not so easy to pull off.
So through a lot of email wrangling, we identified a cohort like this.
This is the MST Spectrum cohort, which longitudinally followed
about 100 high-grade serous ovarian cancer patients and profiled them
using single-cell RNA-Seq and other data modalities.
And again, high-grade serous is not a disease that is ever associated with
cachexia. But what we find is that for 13 patients where we
had single cell,
we are able again to stratify them into type A, type B, and type C
patients. Sometimes these patients had multiple samples collected.
And what you see, you would anticipate that actually inflammatory signaling is
localized to the type A patients. That's not what we see in our hands.
In fact, what we see is that in the tumor cells,
inflammatory signaling is only elevated in type B patients.
Those are the ones that are experiencing organ atrophy.
But actually, if you look outside of the tumor compartment into the myeloid
compartment, that's where we see
elevated interferon or downstream
interferon-stimulated gene signatures.
So I would say we haven't really pinned it down, and my suspicion is that if we
look in other diseases, we'll see different patterns.
I don't really anticipate that we'll see this over and over again, but the data
will tell. So okay. I want to leave you with a few parting
thoughts. This is not a summary of my talk,
but I think that right now the time is ripe for a
new kind of science organized around cachexia that
brings the precision medicine paradigm to bear on studying
physiologic
paraneoplasia like cachexia. And I think the key challenge, which many of
us are already aware of,
is that if you're going to identify subtypes, you actually need to identify the
molecular targets that you could intervene on
to address
those subtypes. And the final thought I want to leave you with is that, in my
view, cachexia is really a grand challenge, not just for
cancer biology, but specifically for computational biology.
This is a setting where you cannot just carry out fancy
molecular measurements and make heat maps in order to make real advances.
The problem is more complicated than that because cachexia is inherently
behavioral, it's physiologic, and it has molecular underpinnings.
And so you need strong computational biologists and
thinkers in order to make progress.
And so
I leave this sort of as an open call for computational biologists who
want to work on an actually hard problem to come into
our field.
So with that, I'll just thank the people who did this and the funding agencies.
And importantly, I left some people out on this slide, especially David
Lydon,
Bill Jarnagin, and Robert Schwartz, and I'll take any questions. Thank you.
Thanks, Ed.
Thanks, Ed. Very inspiring there at the end. We'll open the floor for questions.
Yeah, that was very
inspiring.
Quick question. Did you look at other disease types that develop cachexia to
see if you see these three subtypes in those, like after MI
or COPD? Oh.
So I work at a referral institution for cancer patients.
I guess we haven't really thought about
cachexia associated with MI or burns or something.
We could do it, although it would be hard at our
institution just because
I don't know how prevalent those- Well, you have the models.
You just need a clinical partner to get you that information.
But to do it at scale is hard. To do it at scale, I think is really hard.
Yeah. Well, you have big expectations with 50,000 patients.
Yeah. Just saying, that's-
Yeah ... very rare. Yeah.
And so with that, my next comment will probably bounce off the wall, but we have
1,500 lung cancer patients that have resectable disease that we
have longitudinal CTs on
blood RNA-Seq,
if you want to collaborate. Yeah. I'll come sit right next to you after I'm done.
Okay.
Yeah.
Very interesting talk. A couple observations in
PDAC patients,
both rodent and human. As you're probably
aware with tumor burden in mice, you get splenomegalia
And we were blessed with getting about 60 spleens
from PDAC patients,
and most of them had splenomegalia,
and there's quite an increase in myelohiperplasia, which is
the same thing you see in mice. So I'm
guessing a lot of what you're seeing in the splenomegaly and
probably in the liver is myeloplasia,
extramedullary myeloplasia with myeloid cells.
So-
Certainly, you can get two, three fingers of splenomegaly in some of these
patients.
Yeah. I think at least for the liver observation,
our thinking was that it was steatosis because these patients are just losing a ton
of fat and the liver needs to handle it.
And my understanding is that in other settings, when you lose fat or weight
really quickly, you often develop steatotic liver.
And for the splenomegaly, I'm less sure.
But it tracks with NOR, right? So-
Right. Yeah
Yeah.
So it's probably consistent with some splenomegaly.
Hi. Very interesting talk. I was wondering,
so as the patients receive various forms of therapy,
a lot of them are highly inflammatory.
So I was wondering, do you see, for instance, specifically
chemotherapy and radiation therapy, could they be driving factors for cachexia,
or is it the disease itself that's like that?
And if not, do you see the therapy being a factor in terms
of augmenting cachexia?
Yeah, it's a really important question.
I think it's one of the central questions in our group.
I don't think we have a good framework for...
It's actually my student's PhD thesis or some aspect of it.
I don't think we have a good framework for teasing apart the role of
therapy, and I think, and it has to do with a lot of reasons.
But
it is just very difficult in a causal framework,
I guess, to ascribe
the weight loss or a change in body composition to therapy or not.
I think there are settings where you can do it, like in a clinical trial-
Mm-hmm
... but we don't know. And I think it's sort of this pervasive question in the
field, which is: What does therapy do to
patients? And it's clear that the physicians know something
intuitively about it because I always get this question,
and it seems as if what they're trying to tell me is that we know that
therapy is inducing weight loss through side effects or toxicities in our
patients. But what we're having trouble with is building a
framework where we understand whether weight loss is
a side effect or a natural outcome of the tumor.
I don't know that we have a good way of
discriminating between the two yet.
I see. Have you been able to look at patients with the same tumor
type that have received different therapies to see how the-
Yeah
... cachexia trajectory has gone?
Yeah. That's what we're trying to do.
You can talk to Jamie, who's in the purple shirt right there.
He doesn't have all the answers, but he thinks about it a lot. Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi, I'm Matthias from Ohio State University.
Great talk. Thank you so much for that. Very inspiring.
I was wondering if your group was able to discern patients, for example,
who had other causes
like dysphagia or cancers that are blocking-
Yeah
... their
GI tract-
Yeah
... as a way to-
No.
So we're going to try and do it. I think that, yeah, you're raising an example of
a very important wrinkle in the problem.
So I think, for example, almost all of our esophageal gastric
patients probably have dysphagia, and there is a
question as to whether their weight loss is simply caused by
that.
Yeah.
Interestingly, we have some preliminary data where we can
track the weight loss patterns of esophageal gastric
patients prior to diagnosis, and you see that they start losing weight
about six months before they show up at the doctor.
I don't know that that tells you so much, but my hunch is
just that you wouldn't live with dysphagia for six months.
I don't know if there's an example of-
Oh, they do
... subclinical dysphagia.
They do.
They do? Okay.
Yeah. I treat head and neck cancer.
So
you have patients have nine months, a year before-
Oh, really?
... they actually hit a doctor, and they're just like, "Oh, I thought it was
something that
food-
I see
... gets caught in my throat for
a long time."
Yeah. Then I guess we have to go back to the drawing board a little bit and think
about it. Yeah. I think for almost every disease, there are examples of
things like this, like pancreas cancer and loss of exocrine
function, liver cancer, a similar thing.
And yeah, we just don't have a good framework for thinking about it. Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay. Final question.
Yeah. Just a quick last question. Yong Chae from Northwestern.
So among those three subtypes,
have you looked at across all tumor types, but more importantly, within
each tumor types that it had any survival impact?
Yeah.
Understanding they all had different therapies, but at least-
I don't know that I can go back, but yeah, so the type A is certainly associated
with worse overall survival. We have a way to
also ascertain progression-free survival, and if you buy our
approach, by PFS as well across most diseases, the
inflammatory subtype, type A, is associated with worse outcomes.
Yeah. They progress faster.
Mm-hmm. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much.
We'll next move on to Rich Dunn.
Okay, and that's a tough act to follow, Ed,
but I'm going to try to do my best.
I want to thank the organizers for the invitation to speak with you today.
So my name is Richard Dunn. I'm a GI oncologist at the
University of Rochester, and I'm going to be speaking to you more on
some of the clinical and symptom
subtypes that we're seeing emerge in our data set in an
observational study. So here are my disclosures.
And so yeah, we've
already
discussed
what the
broad definitions of cachexia are. Marcus and Ed have alluded to it.
The most commonly cited definition is the international consensus definition,
which define cachexia as a multifactorial syndrome defined by
ongoing loss of skeletal muscle mass with or
without loss of fat mass that cannot be reversed by nutritional
support alone, that leads to progressive functional impairment,
and several diagnostic criteria
have been proposed and validated
with the most commonly cited as patients with cancer who
experience greater than 5% weight loss in the previous
six months or greater than 2% weight loss plus either low
BMI
or measured muscle loss. So this is a very
large umbrella
that is placed around cachexia.
So all tumor types,
patients experiencing, in some degree, small amounts of weight
loss or significant amounts of weight loss
in form of 5%. So,
this is a large umbrella, but is cancer cachexia really one
disease?
And I think there have been
several studies in the past
that have looked at
there being actually subtypes in cachexia.
20 years ago, Ken Fearon's group
showed that there were varying levels of inflammation found in patients with
pancreatic cancer and weight loss, and not every patient had
issue with anorexia that developed weight loss.
And then later, Teresa Zimmer's group looked at body
composition in patients with pancreatic cancer.
And I thought an important quote from this manuscript was that the
identification of these phenotypes is important because their
existence suggests molecular and/or genetic
heterogeneity among the hosts or tumors as the driving
force for each wasting pattern. And
so,
there are these subtypes that have been shown in the literature
previously,
and yet in our clinical trials,
it has very much been studied and evaluated our
interventions as one disease.
Looking back several decades at different appetite stimulants,
megestrol, which is Megace,
and dronabinol was evaluated in patients
with any advanced cancer that had weight loss.
The ROMANA trials, which were looking at anamorelin,
which is a ghrelin agonist,
looked at patients with advanced non-small cell lung
cancer. And the POWER study looked at osarm,
enobosarm, in a similar population.
And then all the way to today,
the largest ongoing interventional study is being run through
the Alliance of Clinical Trials, looking at
olanzapine in advanced cancer
with
weight loss. So although we think there
are potentially subtypes within cachexia,
currently what we're seeing is a
one-size-fits-all treatment strategy.
Now recently, there have been advances in
targeting subsets of cachexia, which many of you are aware of.
Ponatugumab is an anti-GDF15 antibody.
GDF15 is a stress cytokine that's overexpressed in
cancer, is also augmented by some cancer therapies.
I think that was a great question asking about different therapies, how that could
augment cachexia.
And in this trial blocking GDF15,
they enrolled patients with not only weight loss in
colorectal, lung, and pancreatic cancer, but also patients that had elevated
GDF15, and found that improvements that were seen
in weight, non-sedentary physical activity, and cachexia
symptoms. So this is a randomized phase two trial.
There is a phase three trial in pancreatic cancer that is underway.
But this is proof of concept that molecular subtypes of
cachexia can be targeted therapeutically.
And so, I think the goal will be to try to move away
from this one-size-fits-all treatment strategy and
understand the various complexities of cachexia
and develop targeted therapeutic strategies.
And so, I'm fortunate to work with a team of
researchers that's funded by the Cancer Grand Challenge.
Our team is made up of basic scientists, translational
researchers, and I'm one of the
researchers that's leading some of our clinical studies.
And so what I'm going to share with you today is an ongoing study.
It's an observational study, and our overall objective is
to amass the largest prospective cohort study to evaluate
cachexia with a goal to identify therapeutically
relevant cancer cachexia phenotypes using an expansive
list of candidate variables, including blood and tumor
biomarkers, body composition, physical function testing,
cancer outcomes, and patient-reported
outcomes.And so
this study is not really one study, it's actually two studies
with identical protocols, two sister studies.
One is being run out of Kaiser Permanente called the
UNCOVER study.
And in this study they're recruiting 800 patients, and the
idea is through latent class analysis to derive patient cachexia
clusters.
Once these clusters are identified, we
hypothesize it could be anywhere from two to eight different clusters that emerge.
There'll be a group of clinical expert stakeholders that will narrow the subtypes
to prevalent, clinically interpretable, and potentially
actionable subtypes that will then be independently
validated in the Lotus study, which is being run through the
University of Rochester NCOR research base.
And this is a
nationwide cohort.
We're currently in the middle of enrollment.
This month we anticipate that we'll enroll our 1,000th patient,
and we expect to wrap up enrollment next year, and it's been pretty
swift, and it's been great to see the excitement and the momentum
behind the study.
I'm going to talk to you a little bit about the Lotus study, which is the study
that I lead.
This
could not be done without the NCI Community Research
Oncology Program,
the NCOR, which allows us to enroll
patients from community oncology clinics across the
US. So we have patients enrolled as far west as Hawaii and
the West Coast through the Midwest and
New York and the Eastern Seaboard.
And so I'm going to talk a little bit about the schema and
then just some preliminary analysis of the patient-reported outcomes.
So we enroll patients with advanced lung,
pancreatic, or colorectal cancer.
And I think it's important to point out that we're not just recruiting patients
that have some element of reported weight loss or
cachexia. We're recruiting patients that have advanced
forms of these tumor types who are early on in the disease process.
And the hope is that we actually will recruit some patients who do not develop
cachexia, and we'll have a kind of a baked-in control arm.
And so these patients are followed for about a year,
and as I said, this protocol is similar in the Kaiser
cohort as well.
And so
we collect cancer and medical histories in a chart review.
We do patient-reported outcomes, which I'll talk a little bit more about.
Physical function testing. We'll measure patients' activity levels
both at baseline and follow-up, as well as tracking their
sleep. We do testing for blood biomarkers,
and we're collecting archive tumor sample now.
Having available tissue isn't a requirement to enroll, but the yield has actually
been pretty high, and we're getting tumor tissue from about 60% of patients
enrolled. And then we upload an imaging scan to look
at their body composition,
which Ed was discussing earlier.
And we do this again at follow-up, and
we follow these patients for a year, as I said.
So just some baseline characteristics of the patients we've recruited thus far in
the Lotus study.
It wasn't really intended this way, but we've recruited about a third of
each tumor type,
and over half patients present at enrollment
with already greater than 5% weight loss.
Not surprisingly, patients with pancreatic cancer have high
degrees of cachexia at enrollment.
And then looking at this cohort but breaking it down to patients
that have stable weight and who are experiencing 5% weight loss at
enrollment, as you might imagine, similar to the last study,
the weight loss group is made up of more patients with pancreatic cancer and less
patients with lung cancer, and our weight loss group tends to be a little younger,
and not surprisingly, having a low BMI at diagnosis.
So
what I'm going to focus on for the last few minutes here is
just giving a flavor of some of our patient-reported outcome and some of our
symptom data.
One of the most complete parts of our data set as we're in the middle
of this study is our
surveys on baseline symptoms. And so
we collect about 20 minutes worth of patient surveys,
looking at quality of life, fatigue, anorexia,
and a battery of cachexia symptoms, pain, depression, anxiety,
their appetite,
as well as their sleep. And
so not surprisingly, these symptoms are
highly associated with weight loss, particularly at the
top.
And so
I want to pause at this slide for a minute here.
So we performed a clustering analysis of symptoms,
and I thought we found a few interesting things.
So first I'll point out this green bar.
So the green bar is a cluster of patients that have
very low overall symptom burden. So now this cohort or this
graph here are about 200 patients so far that we enrolled
that have 5% weight loss at enrollment.
And so you see this green
bar that shows really low symptom burden.
Zero patients in this cohort, about 50 of them report
fatigue. Very few have issues with
appetite, and they're very low emotional
distress burden.And then the top bar, our red,
is a cluster of patients that have very high symptom burdens.
So virtually all patients are having issues
with their physical
well-being and their function,
high rates of anorexia and loss of appetite,
and nearly all of them have fatigue, and there are high amounts of
emotional distress. And so there's a couple of symptoms that
I think really differentiate these clusters, fatigue being
one of them, as I alluded to, whereas in some
clusters, it's virtually all patients are
experiencing significant fatigue, and then there's some patients with weight loss
who have none, and then an appetite as well.
And then we have this middle cluster that's kind of a mix between the two other
clusters. So they have a high degree of physical symptoms,
reports of poor function, issues with appetite, but
very little in terms of emotional distress and kind of
in some of the psychosocial
symptoms that we're evaluating very much mirrors the low symptom burden
cluster.
And so, looking at this cohort and some of the clinical outcomes that
we have in this kind of preliminary analysis,
looking at the patients who have stable weight versus those that have weight loss
at enrollment,
actually not a lot of differences in terms of some clinical parameters that we
look at,
so very similar in terms of rates of treatment delays, dose
reductions, hospitalizations, those that are responding to
treatment. But when we look at them based on their symptom cluster,
we start to see them differentiate.
And so that green bar, that low symptom burden that I showed
very much resemble the patients without cachexia.
So patients with weight loss, low symptom burden very much do
well, and actually in some parameters look like they're doing better than
those patients without cachexia.
And the patients with the high symptom burden, not surprisingly,
have
a lot less physical activity, they have higher rates of use of
appetite stimulants and higher rates of disease progression
at just a short period of time after enrollment at three months.
And so we're starting
to look at some of the biomarker data that's coming in.
So this is from the other study at Kaiser Permanente, which is led by Elizabeth
Feliciano and Betty Kahn looking at a host of
biomarkers, again
broken down by cluster of a high symptom burden
versus lower symptom burden, and these are compared to non cachexia
controls. And what we see in patients with higher symptom burden are
higher rates of elevation in GDF15 in the
serum as well as higher inflammatory
markers that are tested like IL6 and IL8.
And so what we're seeing thus far,
the study is ongoing. We're about two-thirds
of the way through recruitment, so there's still a lot of unanswered
questions, but we're starting to see these little fractals
of
different either clinical characteristics or body composition
characteristics,
different levels in some of the important biomarkers that may
have
links to cachexia mechanism. And really our
job over the
next year or so is really to try to make sense of these fractals,
and we hope that
what will be the ultimate output of this study will be
various phenotypes where we can use that to
develop mechanism-driven interventional trials.
So in conclusion, prior and recent evidence supports the
hypothesis that there are subtypes of cancer cachexia, yet clinical trial
design historically and even currently
has been rudimentary, and our studies seek to develop and validate
a new classification of cachexia subtypes.
So in preliminary baseline analysis of patient-reported outcomes,
symptom clusters among those classically characterized as
cachexia emerge, including a cluster of relatively
asymptomatic individuals that resemble the weight
stable cohort. And I think Ed alluded to this a little bit in his
talk, are these patients merely at different points of their
cachexia journey and they will go on to develop more symptoms,
or do they have divergent disease paths requiring
different therapeutic strategies?
And so we hope that our longitudinal study can answer some of these key
questions.
And with that, I'd like to acknowledge our trial
participants and their families as well as our
study site coordinators who are working with our patients
daily across the United States. And I'd
like to thank our funders, Cancer Grand Challenge, the National Cancer
Institute, and the NCORP,
our collaborators at Kaiser Permanente,
as well as our Cancer Grand Challenge research team.
So I'll stop there.
Okay, we could open the floor to questions.
Maybe I
can ask the first question. I'm surprised I don't know, but during the
surveys that you took of patients, did you
collect information on whether they were intentionally losing weight before they
arrived for their cancer diagnosis?
Yeah. I don't know if there's that specific question,
are you intentionally losing weight?
But the fact
cachexia-survey has a question that
kind of looks like that.
Mm-hmm.
And so yeah, you could break down
to very singular questions to see if you can look at behavior
more
with a large data set like this, but we haven't really gotten that granular
yet.
And Rich, you alluded to this with the pieces of the puzzle slide, which I
really liked.
But how do you think our symptom clusters
overlay with the body comp clusters? Or is there any way to address that?
Yeah.
That's a good question. I think one of
Ed's body composition cluster was there wasn't much
wasting.
And it may be that those are the most
asymptomatic or have the least symptoms, but we have to do the
research, so we'll see. Hopefully, we'll find something interesting.
All right. Oh, I think we have some-- Yep.
Oh, okay.
Hi. Great talk.
I noticed from one of your
slides that you saw low hematocrit and low
RBC as not being correlated with worse cachexia outcomes,
but I think from Ed's paper that low hematocrit and
anemia parameters was associated with poor
cachexia. So I'm just wondering-
Yeah
... if you can comment on the discrepancy.
Yeah, I think
this kind of preliminary analysis, it was done in
Marcus's labs. How many patient was that?
Was it only like 100 or?
400 or so.
Was it 400 patients? So,
it's probably only a quarter of
the patients that we actually have, and so I think it's a
little too early to say that they're discorded yet, but
we're trying to see if we can
recapitulate some of the things that are seen in a larger data set. Good question.
All right. Thank you very much, Rich.
Okay, I'll be third speaker in this session.
Just wanted to also reiterate my thanks to the ACR, who's been very supportive
of cachexia research over the past few years, and thank Paul and
Alice for putting together an excellent program this year.
Here are my disclosures again.
So as we've already talked about a few times,
it's a multi-organ systemic disease of cachexia,
which likely originates from the tumor or some component of
the tumor microenvironment, including the stroma, the immune
infiltrates, and of course, factors that are made by the tumor and then
ultimately are secreted and can impact many organs,
including the atrophy programs in the muscle and adipose tissue, as
well as reprogramming in the liver and changes in the immune system.
This is data from Ed's cohort, specifically looking at the lung cancer
population. As you can see, cachexia is extremely common in this
population and also very hazardous.
After a bout of cachexia,
the overall survival probability is dramatically reduced
in comparison to patients that don't have cachexia yet.
Part of that poor survival is due to poor
responses to therapy. And one example of this that has come up multiple
times now in the literature is that people with
cachexia have a poor response to immune
checkpoint inhibitor therapy. And here are some examples of that data
over four different publications of modest sample
size. And you can see that in each case, individuals with cachexia
have much shorter progression-free survival than those without
cachexia.
So we decided to take a look at this in a
small cohort that we have at NYU. These are patients with
advanced lung adenocarcinoma receiving immune checkpoint inhibitor
therapy, and they've been nicely phenotyped and tracked over
time, and there were serial body weights available on our electronic medical
record, such that we could define patients as having cachexia
or not. And then we can center ourselves around the start of the immune
checkpoint inhibitor therapy and come up with a pre-time
point and a post-time point, very much inspired by Ed's
work.
And we found four phenotypes when we did this analysis.
There were patients that we call non-cachectic, where they did not have any weight
loss preceding the immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy, and they also did not have
any change in their body weight after the initiation of therapy.
There was also a group we refer to as cachexia or cachexia continued,
which is they developed cachexia or weight loss before the
onset of immunotherapy, and then the immune therapy didn't modulate that
at all. They just continued to lose weight over
time. We then have a group which is
referred to as cachexia started with treatment, also referred to as a
treatment adverse event,
or it could be considered that, where the body weight was relatively
flat leading up to the onset of immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy, and
then there was a very dramatic reduction in body weight after the onset of
treatment. And then lastly, this is the most ideal case in terms of the
patient outcomes, which is patients had cachexia
before the onset of immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy, and that was reversed by
the therapy.
So these changes patterns in body weight led us to
consider and hypothesize what could be driving the underlying etiology
of these patterns. And so we looked at some clinical
demographic and tumor characteristics of these patients, and we
noticed a few interesting
associationsThe first was, let me
see if I can highlight here.
There was very similar demographics in terms of age,
sex, race,
and BMI.
The things that were different here, I highlight, which is PD-L1
high tumors. So those tended to be enriched in patients that had their
cachexia reversed or had the onset of
wasting at the induction of treatment, suggesting
that having high PD-L1 expression leads to a
robust systemic effect both in a positive and negative way.
We also had resist criteria that was done to evaluate the tumor responses,
and you see that those that had a partial response were all in
the cachexia reversed category,
which is, I think, intuitive and what we would expect.
Those that had progressive disease were enriched in the
cachexia continued group.
And those that there were a higher proportion of patients that were
deceased at two years or before two years, they were also
enriched in the cachexia continued. So I think some of this is sort of intuitive.
If the cachexia is continuing, it's likely that the tumor is not
responding, and we were able to show that in the data here.
And this data suggests that the cachexia trajectory is at least
associated with the immune checkpoint inhibitor response and even may predict that
response.
So there are many common features if you look across the
literature that are shared with the
cachectic process and resistance to immune checkpoint inhibitor, and I'm
listing some of those here. Many of them include pro-inflammatory
cytokines that are released from the tumor microenvironment.
And some of these, like the IL-6/STAT3 pathway, have been associated with
both muscle wasting and also these
myeloid suppressing cells in the tumor microenvironment.
And also lipids like prostaglandins, specifically
prostaglandin E2, that have been implicated in reducing appetite
in different sickness conditions and also in T cell suppression.
So this begged the question, is cachexia inherently linked to
changes in tumor microenvironment that then predict the response to immune
checkpoint inhibitor therapy? And so we turn to preclinical models
in order to try to gain some insight into this.
So this is our favorite preclinical model in the lab.
It's a model of lung cancer that has a KRAS
activating mutation, and also it loses a tumor suppressor, SDK11,
also called LKB1, and we refer to these mice as KL mice.
And over the years, we have profiled these mice and tried to intervene on
cachexia. And one notable feature of this animal model
is that many of the mice develop cachexia.
However, there is this non-cachectic group that are
littermates of these animals and develop similar tumor burden but don't lose
weight, and we've been able to compare the mice that lose weight to the mice that
don't lose weight.
And this is what one of these typical cohorts look like.
You induce the animal model at zero time, and then you watch them over time,
measuring body weight serially, and you can see that the majority will lose
weight, ultimately reaching upwards of 20% weight loss, whereas the
non-cachectic animals don't have any weight loss, yet they
develop ample amounts of tumor. And those that develop weight loss
lose skeletal muscle and adipose tissue and have many other
features consistent with human cachexia, especially with lung cancer.
It's known in the field that this KL model also has very poor
responses to immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy, and this has been shown now for
over 10 years.
Treatment with different interventions.
Here, I'm showing you examples of anti-PD-L1.
You can see that the change in tumor compared to untreated mice,
if you look at the anti-PD-L1 antibody two weeks after treatment, you have
basically the same amount of tumor burden.
And if you look at survival curves, you really don't have any difference between
the black line and this light blue line in terms of overall survival
after initiation of therapy.
So to gain some insights on what could be driving this, we've looked
deeply into the tumors of mice with and without cachexia, and we've done
cytokine profiling in the tumor and also the serum.
And we've identified many IL-6 family members that are
uniquely enriched in the animals with cachexia.
And we've also looked at the immune cells that are present and
could be driving the production of these cytokines.
And when we do a single cell, there's these two different myeloid
populations that are uniquely enriched in the cachectic animals.
One of them is this arginase positive macrophage, and one is a
neutrophil that happens to express high degrees of prostaglandin
synthesis machinery.
And if you look at our RNA sequencing, you see higher markers
of immune exhaustion markers
in the cachectic mice.
Here's just an example of some of the gene expression from the neutrophils that
are enriched in the cachectic animals, and I'm showing you one example
of this prostaglandin synthesis machinery, which is a gene called
PTGS2, also referred to as COX-2, which is very important for
prostaglandin production.
And they are uniquely enriched in the neutrophils.
They also can be found in the tumor cells themselves.
And if you go in the tumors and you measure prostaglandin E2, you see that it's
significantly higher in the cachectic mice.
If you go back to our human data set, and this data set is
nice because a pulmonologist was helping us collect the data, and he
collected bronchoalveolar lavage fluid from the region
outside the tumor.
And we can sample that fluid, and we can do
RNA sequencing on the cells from that fluid, and we can also do measurements
like prostaglandin E2 from that fluid.
And if you segregate patients with and without cachexia, you see that the patients
with cachexia also have high levels of prostaglandin E2 in the
bronchoalveolar lavage fluid. And if you do sequencing on the tumor
cells from that fluid, you see that they are enriched in prostaglandin
signaling.So
in order to test the contribution of PGE2 to
cachexia, we partnered with Thalise
Papagiannakopoulos,
who's here at AACR.
If you have any specific questions and want to reach out to him.
So this is a model in which
we have KRAS and LKB1, very similar to what I've been talking to you, but these
mice also have inducible expression of Cas9, and this
allows us to
both induce the tumors using a lentivirus cre, and also deliver a
guide RNA to the tumors such that the tumors that we turn on
the activating mutations, we can also manipulate different genes in those tumor
cells. And one of the genes that we first attempted to manipulate in
collaboration with Thalise's lab was PTGS2.
I'm sorry, PTGES, which is the last step in forming
prostaglandin E2.
And so when you do this, you can now see that PGE2 levels are
dramatically suppressed in the animals that receive the guide RNA versus animals
that don't receive a control guide RNA.
And then if you follow their body weight trajectories, you can see that the
knockdown of PTGES
prevents or delays the onset of cachexia quite significantly.
And in a separate model,
through another of our collaborators, Tony Hui,
we can perform a very similar cre CRISPR
mediated deletion of PTGS2, and this was done in
an allograft model in the C26 cells.
And you can see that this, in comparison to a non-cachectic C26,
the cachectic inducing C26 cell line leads to higher
amounts of PGE2 in the tumors,
and the CRISPR base knockout completely
reduces that amount of PGE2.
And then when you track their body weights over time, what you can see is that
the animals that have the PTGS2 knocked out are
protected from body weight loss in comparison to the cachectic C26
line.
So these data suggest that the PGE2
can be contributing to cachexia,
and work from Thalise's lab now in review, and work from Liberles's lab,
which was done in a setting of influenza, have very nicely shown that local
PGE2 can be detected by sensory neurons that then link
back to the brain in order to reduce appetite and contribute to wasting.
And this data's in review, but I think it'll be very convincing once it's out.
But we were wondering what could be the trigger for this PGE2
production, since these neutrophils are present and releasing
this prostaglandin. Is there an upstream trigger other than the tumor cells
themselves that can be leading to this?
And we started to think about what triggers this neutrophil
production, and one of the thoughts were that local bacteria could
be inducing this activated
neutrophil state. And we started to look using 16S,
is there dysbiosis in the cachectic tumors?
And you can see here an example of a cachectic versus non-cachectic tumor,
where the density of the 16S in the tumors is much greater in the
cachectic animals.
I should also note that these are much stronger
when the tumor is located near the airway, suggesting that
the increase in the tumor next to the airway can promote this
dysbiotic phenotype.
And data from a collaborator at NYU, Leo
Segal, had a very nice experiment that's
helping us validate some of these findings, where he uses a tumor cell line
that does not induce cachexia. You can see here in green,
this wild-type cell line, which is KRAS driven, loss of
TP53.
You don't get any weight loss. You also have very low neutrophils.
And you can also give mice a dysbiotic cocktail,
which includes bacteria that can modulate directly
into the lungs, and they house in the lungs, and they produce a small
inflammatory reaction. If you do that alone without the tumor cells, you also
don't lose weight, but you generate a little bit of neutrophilia.
I'm sorry, the green line is the wild-type mice, no tumors.
The
gray line here is the tumor-bearing mice,
which don't have much weight loss and don't have many neutrophils.
And then you combine the two, where you have tumor cells that are implanted
and the dysbiosis, and now you have much worse survival.
You have induction of weight loss dramatically, and you
have much more neutrophils present.
So just to summarize our current thinking on this model,
I think that there is likely a dysbiosis occurring because of the
tumor, possibly due to the tumor location near large airways.
This is activating local myeloid cells that are producing
prostaglandin E2. These prostaglandins can
reduce food intake.
And the presence of these neutrophils and myeloid suppressor cells are also
blocking the efficacy of the checkpoint inhibitors.
And ongoing work is now manipulating each of these components.
First, we're trying to manipulate neutrophils, several ongoing and complementary
strategies. This is actually very challenging.
Many of you, if you've worked with trying to manipulate neutrophils, they're very
short-lived, and removing them often is transient, and they
come back with a vengeance. And so we have some strategies here,
including a DPP1 inhibitor that we're testing.
And also, we've shown through genetic manipulation that
lowering prostaglandin production can improve cachexia
outcomes, and we're now interested in possibly blocking this signal
using inhibitors that are available for, that were designed to
mitigate pain responses that target the sensory neurons and can block the
effects of prostaglandins on those sensory
neurons.And again, I'll just
highlight
what we talked about today, which is components of the tumor microenvironment,
including immune cells, can produce soluble
factors that can manipulate both cachexia and checkpoint inhibitor
response.
And I'd like to thank members of our team, including local members at
NYU, members of the CANCAN team, and I'd
also like to take this moment to invite you all to a meeting that we're organizing
in London. It's going to be a great meeting on cancer and the host.
The registrations are open. I think we even have some abstract submissions
open. If you're interested, please
write me. Thank you very much.
Happy to take any questions.
Hey, Marcus. Great talk.
So I know you've presented in your KO animals, half of them get
cachexia, half of them don't. I might have missed this, but
are the ones that don't get cachexia, do they have low PGE2?
It's not half and half.
Okay.
It's about 80/20 get cachexia. And if you compare those
with and without cachexia, those with cachexia have much higher PGE2
levels than the ones that don't get cachexia.
Okay. Got it.
And also PGE2's been shown, I guess, to have some muscle
intrinsic effects as well. So do you think that the rescue of cachexia
solely has to do with sensory
innervation, or do you think that it has something to do with
muscle as well?
Well, we can't measure the PGE2 in the plasma.
It's a very
short-lived metabolite and often doesn't make its way and accumulate in the
plasma. So, the connection with PGE2 in the muscle would likely
have to be local production. We haven't measured that, but we know that certainly
it's not circulating.
Thank you, Dr. Gonsalves. This is an amazing talk.
I was
wondering,
since
PGE2 seems to have a more of a central role in this
scenario, have we considered
NSAIDs considering that cyclooxygenase
one and two are rate-limiting steps in the production?
Yes. Well, NSAIDs have had a long history in cachexia research going
back several decades, and there are hints of
an appropriate effect there, like a beneficial effect,
especially in lung cancer, like celecoxib.
There are some small studies that have been done over the years, and
certainly that needs to be revisited given what you've heard from the prior two
talks. Can we make the population
small enough and tight enough where they would see the biggest response?
I think the limitation in that approach is also the adverse events
that come from giving moderate to high doses of NSAIDs.
GI toxicity, bleeding, et cetera.
That's a balance between those and the actual effect, but
that's why I like the sensory neuron inhibition strategy because you
will avoid some of those adverse events.
Thank you.
Oh, great talks.
I have a few questions.
Has anyone tried
COX-2 inhibition in the immune checkpoint blockade?
COX-2 inhibition immune checkpoint... I don't think so.
I mean, so-
That's a good idea
... is that where you're going with that?
That is-- Exactly, yeah. Exactly.
And,
I'm not sure I followed, but are the markers
of these,
of the dysmetabolism and the resistance to immune checkpoint blockade,
these
MAC-3s and N1s, did you see those just in the tumor?
Are they in the periphery as well?
We only see them in the tumor, although if you look at the peripheral
organs, they are infiltrated with
macrophages and neutrophils.
Uh-huh.
We don't know if they're the same subtype.
But if you just do histologic staining for general neutrophil
and macrophage markers, they're also present.
Okay, thanks. And then the last question is a question we got in the last session.
For these 80/20 mice that get cachexia and don't get cachexia,
do the 80% have necrotic regions in their
tumors?
I don't know. That's a good point.
I think there's a whole session on-
I don't think we have done-- Really, I don't think we have looked that carefully
for necrotic regions. Yeah, we'll have to go back and check that out.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah. Thank you for the wonderful talk.
So I'm not from the field of cachexia, so I'm basically doing
microbiome and immunotherapy. So I guess my question
is, have you ever looked into the gut microbiome that
correlate with-- Because you were doing the intratumoral
microbiome. Is there any correlation, or-- Because we know that gut
microbiome is also associated with immunotherapy
response. So is there any correlation between
the intratumoral and gut in terms of-
Yes, we have dabbled in that space.
I could tell you that the gut barrier gets a little leakier in our
cachectic animals. It's not as dramatic as other
publications that have shown, but you do get some of that signal.
We also see some dysbiosis, but this is
all a little biased by the fact that they have such profound anorexia,
and we have not yet done the proper controls that have
that reduction in food intake to normalize out that effect.
So we have some hints of data. And also we, just as
an olive branch for collaboration, we also
collected
50 or so stool samples from
UNCOVER.
50 patients
50 patients with some stool samples from UNCOVER study that have been very well
characterized, as Rich said. So yeah, we'd love to
investigate that further.
Thank you. I guess I have a quick second question.
So it's about the causal correlation between the
PGE2 signaling and the upward cachexia
and the immunotherapy. So basically, the model you were showing
is
the increase of PGE2 and dysbiosis is the causal
reason for the resistant of immunotherapy.
And we can see from the cohort that most people
who recovered from the cachexia is contributed to the
responders. So I guess my question is, if we figure out
how to overcome the immunotherapy outcome without
really targeting the PGE2 signaling,
is it going to be helpful for the
patient to recover from the cachexia even though we didn't touch that?
I would love to know. Yes. Certainly, we can test that in the
animals.
And eventually, if that works, we can move into the human cases.
It would be great in order to find something that can help mitigate
cachexia and/or improve the immune checkpoint responses.
I think now we have the genetic tools, as I showed you, in order to test some of
that. It'd be interesting to see, do the mice that have
low PGE2 that develop equivalent tumor burden, do they now
respond to the immune checkpoint inhibitor? And that's exactly where we're going.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
All right. Well, this was a very fun, interactive session.
Thank you all for your questions. Thank you for joining today, and I think most of
us will stick around if you have any questions after the session.
Thank you very much.